one thing that I do regret one thing I
have not sorted out for myself is how to
navigate the the
professional and personal pressure
that gets
applied at this moment where you have a
friend or an acquaintance or someone you
know
who's behaving badly in public or or
Behaving Badly behaving in a way that
you think is bad in public
and they have a public platform where
they're influencing a lot of people and
you have your own public platform where
you're constantly getting asked to
comment on what this this friend or or
acquaintance or colleague is doing
I haven't known what I think is
ethically right about the choices that
seem forced on us and at moments like
this so like I've criticized you in
public about your interview with Kanye
now in the case in in that case I
reached out to you in private first and
told you exactly what I thought and then
when I was going to get asked in public
or when I was touching that topic on my
uh podcast I more or less said the same
thing that I said to you in private
right now that was how I navigated that
moment
um I did the same thing with you with
Elon uh at least on at the beginning
um
you know this we have we have maintained
Good Vibes that was just which is not
what another Elon but I don't think I I
disagree with you because Good Vibes in
the moment there's a deep core of Good
Vibes that persist through time between
you and Elon and I would argue probably
between some of the other folks you
mentioned I I think with Brett I failed
to reach out in private
uh to the degree that I should have and
we never really had a we we had tried to
set up a conversation in private that
that never happened but
um there was some communication but
it would have been much better for me to
have made more of an effort in private
than I did before it's Spilled Out into
public and I would say that's true with
other people as well
what kind of interaction in private do
you think you should have with Brett
because my case would be beforehand and
now still the case I would like in this
part of the criticism
be sent my way maybe it's useful to go
to that direction actually let's go to
that direction because I think I
disagree with your criticism as you
stated publicly but this is something
yeah the thing you criticize me for is
actually the right thing to do with
Brett okay you you said Lex could have
spoken with Kanye in such a way as to
have produced a useful document he
didn't do that because he has a fairly
naive philosophy about the power of love
so let's see if you can maintain that
philosophy in the presence let's go no
it's beautiful he seemed to think that
if he just got through the Minefield to
the end of the conversation where the
two of them still were feeling good
about one another and they can hug it
out that would be by definition a
success so
let me make the case for this Power of
Love philosophy right and first of all I
I love you Sam you're still an
inspiration and somebody I deeply admire
okay back at you uh the to me in the
case of Kanye
it's not only that you get to the
conversation and have hugs it's that the
display that you're willing to do that
has power so even if it doesn't end in
hugging the actual the turning the other
cheek the act of turning the other cheek
itself communicates both to Kanye later
and to the rest of the world
that we should
have empathy and compassion towards each
other there is power to that that maybe
that is naive but I believe in the power
of that so it's not that I'm trying to
convince Kanye that some of his ideas
are wrong but I'm trying to illustrate
that just the act of listening and truly
trying to understand another human being
that is opens people's minds to actually
questioning their own beliefs more it
takes them out of the dogmatism
de-escalates the kind of uh dogmatism
that I've been seeing so in that sense I
would say the Power of Love is is the is
the philosophy you might apply to Brett
because the right conversation you have
in private is not about Hey listen
you're you know the the experts you're
talking to they seem credentialed but
they're not actually as credentials as
they're illustrating they're not
grounding their findings in an actual
meta-analyzes in the papers and so on
like making a strong case like what are
you doing there's going to get a lot of
people in trouble but instead just
saying like being a friend in the
dumbest of ways being like
respectful sending love their way and
just having a conversation outside of
all of this outside like basically so
showing that like
removing the emotional attachment to
this debate even though you are very
emotionally attached because in the case
of covid specifically there is a very
large number of lies at stake
but removing all of that and remembering
that you have a friendship
yeah well so I think these are highly
non-analogous cases right so your
conversation with Kanye
misfired from my point of view for a
very different reason it was it was
it has to do with Kanye I mean so Kanye
I don't know I've never met Kanye uh so
obviously I don't know him
um but
I think he's either obviously in the
midst of a mental health crisis
or he's a colossal
or both I mean there's actually those
aren't mutually exclusive so one of
three possibilities he's either mentally
ill he's an or he's a he's
mentally ill and an I think all
three of those possibilities are
possible for the both of us as well no
moment I would argue none of those are
are likely for either of us but
um possible not to say we don't have our
moments but
so so the reason not to talk to Kanye so
you I think you should have had the
conversation you had with him in private
that's great and there's no I've got no
uh criticism
of what you said had it been in private
in Pub I just thought
you're not doing him a favor if he's
mentally ill right
if he's in the middle of a a manic
episode or or you know I'm not a
clinician but I've heard it said of him
that he is bipolar um you're not doing
him a favor sticking a mic in front of
him and letting him go off on the Jews
or anything else right
um we know what he thought about the
Jews we know that there's not much
illumination going to cut it's going to
come from him on that topic and if it is
a symptom of his mental illness that he
thinks these things well then it's
you're not doing him a favor making that
even more public
um if he's just an and he's just
an anti-semite in an ordinary you know
Garden variety anti-semite well then
there's also not much to say unless
you're really going to dig in and kick
the out of him in public and I'm
saying you can do that with love I mean
that's the other thing here is that
I don't agree that compassion and love
always have this patient
embracing acquiescence
face right they don't always feel good
to the recipient right there is a sword
of wisdom that you can wield
compassionately in moments like that
where someone's full of and you
just make it absolutely clear to them
and to your audience that they're full
of and it's no there's no hatred
being communicated in fact you could
just it's like listen I'm going to do
everyone a favor right now and you know
just take your foot out of your mouth
and and
um
and the truth is you know I wouldn't I
just wouldn't have aired the
conversation like I just don't think it
was a document that had to get out there
right I I get that many P this is not a
signal you're likely to get from your
audience right I get that many people in
your audience thought oh my God that's
awesome you're talking to Kanye and
you're doing it in Lex style where it's
just love and you're not treating him
like a pariah and you know you're you're
holding this tension between he's this
creative genius who we lose work we love
and yet he's having this moment that's
so painful and you know what a tightrope
walk and I get that maybe 90 of your
audience saw it that way they're still
wrong and I and I still think that was
non-balanced not a good thing to put out
into the world you don't think it opens
up the mind and heart of people that
listen to that just have it it does it's
let if it's opening up in the wrong
Direction Where just gale force nonsense
is coming in right I think we should
have an open mind and an open heart but
there's some clear things here that
that we have to keep in view one is the
mental illness component is its own
thing yeah I don't pretend to understand
what's going on with him so but insofar
as that's the reason he's saying what
he's saying
do not put this guy on camera and let
know but I had to say sorry in that
point real quick I had a bunch of
conversation with them offline and I
didn't get a sense of mental illness
that's why I chose to sit down okay and
I didn't get it I mean mental illness is
such a
but when he shows up in a put on
Alex Jones's podcast I mean this is
either that's more you know genius
performance in his world or it's he's
unraveling further I wouldn't put that
under mental illness I we have to I
think there's another conversation to be
had about
how we treat artists
right because they're they're weirdos
they're very I mean we you know taking
taking words from Kanye as if he he's
like Christopher Hitchens or something
like that like very eloquent researched
you know written many books on history
and politics and geopolitics on
psychology Connie didn't do any of that
he's an artist just spawning off and so
there's a different style conversation
and a different way to treat
the words that are coming out let's
leave the mental illness aside so if
we're going to say that there's no
reason to think he's mentally ill and
this is just him being creative and
Brilliant and opinionated
well then that falls into the
bucket for me it's like then then he's
someone and honestly the most offensive
thing about him in that interview from
my point of view is not the
anti-Semitism which you know we can talk
about because I think there there are
problems just letting him uh
uh spread those memes as well but the
most offensive thing is just how
delusionally egocentric he is or was
coming off in that interview and in
others like he he has an estimation of
himself as this Omnibus genius to to
write not only to rival Shakespeare to
exceed Shakespeare right I mean he's
like he's he is the greatest mind that
has ever walked Among Us and he's more
or less explicit on that point and yet
he manages to talk for hours without
saying anything actually interesting or
insightful or or factually Illuminating
right so it's complete delusion of a
very trumpian sort it's like it's like
you know when Trump says he's a genius
who understands everything but nobody
takes him seriously
and one wonders whether Trump takes
himself seriously Kanye seems to believe
he seems to believe his own press he
actually thinks he's he's you know the
uh just a Colossus and
um he may be a great musician you know
I'm not you know I I've certainly not my
wheelhouse to compare him to any other
musicians but
um
one thing that's patently obvious in
from your conversation is he's not who
he thinks he is intellectually or
ethically or in any other relevant way
and so when you couple that to the
anti-Semitism he was spreading which I
what was genuinely noxious and
ill-considered and
um has potential knock-on effects in the
black community I mean there's a there's
an ambient level of anti-Semitism in the
black community that is worth worrying
about and talking about anyway there's a
bunch of guys you know playing The
Knockout game in Brooklyn just punching
Orthodox Jews in the face
and I think letting Kanye air his
anti-Semitism that publicly only raises
the the likelihood of that rather than
diminishes it I don't know so let me say
just a couple of things so one my belief
at the time
was it doesn't it decreases it showing
empathy while pushing back decreases
likelihood of that it does might it
might on the surface look like it's
increasing it but that's simply because
the anti-Semitism or the hatred in
general is brought to the surface and
that people talk talk about it but I
should also say that you're one of the
only people that wrote to me privately
criticizing me and uh like out of the
people I really respect and admire and
that was really valuable that like I had
to it's painful because I had to think
through it for a while I'm still it
still haunts me because the other kind
of criticism I got a lot of people
basically said
thinks towards me uh based on who I am
that they hate me just just you mean
anti-semitic things or that you're
anti-semitic things I just hate the word
anti-semitic it's a it's like racist but
here's the reality
so I'm someone so I'm Jewish you know
although obviously not religious
um
I have never taken you know I've been a
student of the Holocaust obviously I I
know a lot about that and and there's
reason to
to be a student of the Holocaust but
in my lifetime and in my experience I
have never taken anti-Semitism very
seriously I'm not worried about it I
have not made a thing of it I've done
exactly one podcast on it I had Barry
Weiss on my podcast
um when her book came out
but
it really is a thing and it's uh
it's something we have to keep an eye on
societally because it it it's the it's a
unique kind of hatred right it's a it's
Unique in that
it seems It's knit together with it's
not just ordinary racism it's it's knit
together with lots of conspiracy
theories that never seem to die out
um it's it can by turns equally animate
the left and the right politically I
mean it was so perverse about
anti-Semitism like look in the American
context with the far right you know with
white supremacists Jews aren't
considered white so they hate us in this
In The Same Spirit in which they hate
black people or brown people or anyone
who's not white
but on the left Jews are considered
extra white I mean we're we're the extra
beneficiaries of white privilege right
and in the black community that is often
the case right we're a minority that has
thrived and so and and it seems to stand
as a Counterpoint to all of the problems
of of other other minorities suffer in
particular you know African-Americans in
the American context
um and yeah Asians are now getting a
little bit of this you know like the the
model minority uh uh issue but Jews have
had this going on for centuries and and
Millennia and it never seems to go away
and it's again this is something that
I've never focused on but
this has been at a slow boil for as long
as we've been alive and there's no
guarantee it can't suddenly become much
much uglier than we have any reason to
to expect it to become Even in our
society and so
um there's a there's kind of a special
concern at moments like that where you
have an immensely influential person in
a community
who already has a checkered history with
respect to their own beliefs about the
Jews and the conspiracies and all the
rest uh and he's just messaging uh you
know not especially fully opposed by you
and anyone else who's given him a the
microphone at that moment
to the world and that so that that
you know made my Spidey Sense yeah it's
complicated it's the stakes are very
high and as somebody that's been
obviously family and also reading a lot
about World War II yeah and just this
whole period is a very difficult
conversation but I I I I believe in the
power especially uh given who I am of
um not always but sometimes often
turning the other cheek
oh yeah and again things change
when it when they're for public
consumption you know when you're so it's
like I mean the the cut for me that you
know has just the use case I keep
stumbling upon is the the kinds of
things that I will say on a podcast like
this or if I'm giving a public lecture
versus the kinds of things I will say at
dinner
with strangers or with friends like like
if you're in an elevator like if I'm in
an elevator with strangers I do not fee
and I hear someone say something stupid
I don't feel a an intellectual
responsibility to turn around in that
you know in the con in the confines of
that space with them and say listen that
thing you just said about X Y or Z is
completely false and here's why right
but if somebody says it in front of me
on some public bias where I'm actually
talking about ideas that's when you know
there's a different responsibility that
comes online the question is how you say
it how you say it or even whether you
say anything in in those I mean there
are moments there there are definitely
moments to privilege civility or just to
pick your battles I mean sometimes it's
just not worth it to get into it with
somebody out out in in real life I just
believe in the power of empathy both in
the pr in the elevator and when a bunch
of people are listening
that when they see you willing to
consider the another human being's
perspective
I it just gives more power to your
to your words after
well yeah but until it doesn't like if
because you can
you can right you can extend charity too
far right you could like it can be
absolutely obvious what someone's
motives really are and they're they're
you know dissembling about that right
and so then you're taking at face value
their representations begins to look
like you're just being duped and you're
not you're not actually doing the work
of of putting pressure on a bad actor
you know so it's it's and again the
whole the mental illness component here
makes makes it very difficult to think
about what you should or shouldn't have
said to Kanye